نعم هو كذلك وهو كذلك المعز هذه الفرحه
العربيه التي
تعيد بها كل عربي اليوم هنا في سوق واقف
وفي قطر وفي كل بقاع الارض هذه نسخه
استثنائيه
فوزت تونس على فرنسا
وفضت المملكه العربيه السعوديه على
الارجنتين
وهي المغرب اليوم تتاهل
للدور الربع النهائي
بفوزها المستحق على اسبانيا الشعب المغربي
العربي هنا سعيد بهذه الفرحه
مونديال الكل الكل حمله همم معزه سعيد في
هذه المناسبه
لا تطيع لا استطيع الحديث لانه الاجواء
هنا حماسيه جدا
ترحم في المعز لنخذ لنخذ لنخذ بعض
الجماهير السعيده بهذه المناسبه
اوه مبروك علينا الف الف مبروك الفوز اولا
الله يبارك فيك
تحت وليد الركراكي الله يخليك كان جيد
وشكر لونه وكل الدراري يلعبوا كويس وكل
العرب مبروك لكم بالفعل هو انجاز انجاز
عربي الكل سعيد وانا ناري من جميع اطياف
في الوطن العربي سعيده
اهو المنتخب كان في المستوى ما شاء الله
لعبوا لعبوا كان عليهم ضغط ضغط مدر
الاسباني لكن المنتخب الاسود سووها الاسود
زوار اسود سوالي اسود ان شاء الله يا رب
تعيش المغرب
[تصفيق]
اسود اطلس المغربيه
هذه الميدايه
بالفعل هذه هي البدايه فقط
ونترقب ان شاء الله
لتاهلهم للنهائيات عندك معز